do you want to pull up
um dear Jonah really quickly absolutely
yeah and let me tell you so this is
amazing and you'll love this so I set
out to do a um
[__] phone talking
um so I set out to do a special called
the pandemic special
and
do that again so I set out to do
something called
um the pandemic special and this stuff I
love this so this uh pause right here
pause right here
okay so I set out to do the pandemic
special which is all my pandemic
material because I was like I can't use
it anymore I want to get it almost as a
time capsule and um you you know as you
guys know I'm I'm really an improviser
it's like my strength
and so I did I did so I just but I was
like I need stand up to show people that
I'm a stand-up comic you know that's
just really really important and so what
I um
what ended up happening is I started to
do this show and the first show was
awful I did I did this at Zanies in
Nashville and I mostly because I came up
with this great idea for a backdrop but
also because those were the places I was
playing during the pandemic that was all
ideas these kind of clubs in like
Tennessee and so I I went into the
second show on Friday which is always
really difficult for the most always the
notorious the worst show not seriously
the worst show and the audience was
amazing and I was like oh my God this is
so incredible this is going to be the
special audience and this guy started
heckling me in the front row and I was
like TJ don't pay attention to him just
say the course he's probably gonna be
quiet and he wouldn't stop heckling me
and wanted he was doing weird heckles
like not mean but just like that's good
uh yeah I you know I agree with that or
like yeah that's true that's funny
because it's true so then finally I'm
like this [__] drunk is gonna ruin my
God damn so then I go and I say
something to him about his cargo pants
okay okay and he is not drunk and he is
not a Heckler he's this guy Jonah uh
so he's talking about why he likes
why he likes cargo bags
okay I got you
I want you guys to know that I am not
going to make fun of him at all
is that a great backdrop right it's all
different fake in the Zanies Comedy Club
because the top ones is the real thing
yeah those are all fake huh
yeah tummy Tickler I like my buddies
Nick Vatterott is hilarious like
uncomfortable silences yeah uh so yeah
so that's that was Jonah and so then I
kind of said look I'm not gonna make fun
of this guy yeah it's great and then
throughout the show he like interrupted
me again so I Incorporated him and then
eventually the show was kind of about
him people wanted to hear what he had to
say I was sort of involving he has the
funniest line in the entire special the
closer is something with him that we do
together yeah and it was it's like
perfect because that's exactly it did
everything that I needed to do wow it's
it shows people how how good I am and
it's an improviser and then if you come
see a show you have no idea where it's
going to go it shows that I am a comic
and I have strong material and also
shows that I'm like a good guy yeah
because I never made fun of this guy and
there's never moment where it seems like
I'm going to and I kind of the whole
show spent it slowly kind of lifting him
up and making him the star of the show
oh yeah and it's really sweet I mean
honestly people tell me that at the end
of the special they're like crying
because they're like how is this guy and
you can tell because he's a huge fan of
Deadpool a huge fan of me and I said you
know that I get Sandy goes oh yeah he
said I I saw you before and I was in the
back and he's like so I said I gotta go
and see you again be in the front and
that's why he sat so he was in front he
was touching the stage his table was
such a stage because he figured if it
was good in the back it was gonna be so
much better in the front right because
that's it gets better as you get closer
the performer which is kind of [__]
true that's true yeah and so it's it's
like the best is he normal is there
something going on with him or of course
yeah okay I don't want to know I don't
want to say the word but well I mean
what's funny is he that he's he's
developmentally [__] and I told him
yeah
that thing and I said that and this
there's like this world what's it called
diabolical [__] what is it
gosh what'd you say so listen so he's so
so I was talking about this with my
because this woke or all this comment
because she's really funny but she was
like she kept being like special needs
okay yes absolutely it's oh yeah yeah
but then I'm talking to my
neuropsychologist about it and I said he
he is he's developmentally [__] that
is the name for it
she goes yeah that would have been
insane that would have been so insane
crazy
um and he's just diabolical
uh see he's diabolically so I said that
in uh to my neuropsychologist and she
goes it is still it's a medical term but
we prefer to say intellectually
deficient okay what that's even worse
that's worse yeah painful it's kind of
like no you don't have it it's never
happened instead of calling someone slow
you're like no he stopped yeah
he's not slow he stopped yeah yeah
I think it is worse but there's no way
so whatever it is and special needs is
kind of strange
um
intellectually deficient isn't that
weird that's crazy yeah it's pretty
harsh it's harsh that's what I'm saying
that's why I was like retardation is
just okay like I mean I okay I love it I
don't know if I'm gonna get in trouble
for this probably no you're not um
because you're so nice to him well and
you named a special after the guy yeah
and it's it's sort of a love letter to
him oh you're a good guy is what it
ended up being and so he's in his um his
high school teacher reached out to me
wow and because she was like the
counselor for the special needs kids and
she said I watched that and it was so
amazing and it just made my heart sore
and it brought tear to my eye and she
said and just I know that it means the
world to him and so that was really
really cool and I can't wait to go back
to Tennessee I'm hoping he comes to see
a show because you should go have lunch
with him or something I'd want to hear
what he thinks of the special because
I'm sure he loved it but at the time you
can see he's like he can feel everybody
in this room is sold out it's two or
three hundred whatever it is it's
hundreds and hundreds of people that are
like loving him like just being like we
love this guy you're great you're
hilarious you're doing it and you can
just feel him taking that in because
that doesn't happen to him a lot a lot
of the time people are making fun of him
or they want him to get out of the way
in the grocery store or they think that
what parking incorrectly or whatever it
is nobody's patient with him get out of
the way